[Music]
good evening and welcome to tucker
carlson tonight midterm elections are
just months away and no matter what you
hear the truth is Democrats do have its
strong chance of taking over the House
of Representatives if history is any
guide what does that mean well the short
term it means that Nancy Pelosi will get
unfettered subpoena power Maxine Waters
is likely to be chairman of the
Financial Services Committee it will be
a big deal but more broadly it means an
ascendant Democratic party and not the
party you grew up with but a new and far
more radical and far more intolerant
version of that party how radical well
last night we showed you the violence
tonight we have exclusive new material
the product of our reporting just two
weeks ago progressive activists held the
convention in New Orleans called
Netroots nation happens every year
virtually every major Democrat running
for president went by the fast evolving
standards of the Left Netroots nation is
a mainstream gathering it's not a fringe
event well this show sent an
investigative team to Netroots nation to
find out what the Democratic Party is
becoming the very first thing we noticed
is that socialism long discredited by
nearly a century of murder and suffering
is reemerging and moving toward the
center of democratic politics what I see
is not a time for moderation it's a time
for progressives to double down on what
we believe in the establishment is
terrified of that word socialism but if
we learned one thing from the Obama
years it's that Republicans are going to
call us socialists no matter what we do
so we might as well give them the real
thing
[Applause]
might as well give them real socialism
the crowd cheers just 10 years ago
Democrats nodded to the idea of border
security they said they were for it now
the very idea of immigration enforcement
of any kind of borders themselves is
considered repugnant on the left I
happen to believe that an agency that
has repeatedly systematically and
violent and violently committed human
rights abuses cannot be reformed just
imagine no wall no wall in southern
Arizona disagree with that think open
borders are a bad idea you're not simply
wrong in the eyes of the new left you're
immoral the Republicans will continue to
practice the politics of division they
will keep right on attacking anyone who
dares to stand up to the rich and the
powerful do you need to wait for robert
muller to tell you trump is wildly
corrupt we must defeat a republican
party which has sold its soul to a
republican a republican president
without one president has no soul
republicans are in the pocket of the
rich says the hedge fund private equity
party the president of course denounced
as a racist while actual race baiters
like Maxine Waters who once encouraged
race riot were lauded as heroes
President Trump and do your race bathing
and make your racial statements whether
it's LeBron James or Maxine Waters or
anybody else that ain't playing anymore
President Trump well ironically for a
gathering they said was designed to
empower the marginalized voters of color
as they say attendees at this event
tended to skew much older paler and more
affluent well a group of progressive
activists noticed this and a group of
them stormed the stage during Saturday's
keynote speeches they demanded more
black representation and they promised
to drink the crowds quote white tears
that white fragility is suing
those white tears are sewing but guess
what I'm ready to drink them because we
are going to be on the board you're
going to let us on the board and you're
going to fight for us to be on the board
of networks ready to drink white tears
on an effort to atone for their skin
color organizers did what they could to
attack white America among the books
distributing the event was one called
Brown is the new white how demographic
revolution has created a new American
majority one poster we found said that
one of the quote challenges for American
democracy is that white voters are able
to vote and elect officials in any other
venue that would of course be described
as racism but it was normal ad net roots
and then there were the bizarre portions
of the program and there were a lot of
those one well-attended panel dealt with
a matter of quote menstrual equity this
is the latest frontier in the civil
rights movement in case you've been on
vacation one elected Democrat from
Virginia we spoke to said mail access to
tampons is a vital and important
emerging issue we're not sure how many
men who are are menstruating based on
that transgender surgeries or other ways
that they're transforming we're not sure
how many men are menstruating happily
the Democratic Party is trying to find
out even as you sleep it went on like
this this is what the Democratic Party
is running on in 2018 the end of free
enterprise vicious attacks on a huge
portion of the American population
solely because of their skin color
tampons in men's bathrooms this is a
movement that seeks to end borders and
create a world where there are only two
kinds of people the 320 million American
citizens who live here you and me and
the seven billion US citizens who
haven't gotten around to moving here yet
but if every right to move here when
they feel like it that would be the rest
of the world
that's what utopia looks like if you're
a member of the New York Times editorial
board but what if you're not what if
you're just an ordinary voter is any of
this appealing we'll find out in
November